all right guys
bang bang i've got a very very very
special treat for us today
i have my friend and colleague
colton here with me what's up man what's
going on thanks for having me
all right before we get started though
i'm gonna tell a story as to how colton
and i met which is a ridiculous but true
story
so maybe six to eight months ago i can't
remember exactly when i tweeted out
and i said if you send me fire memes
i will have no choice but to share them
as kind of an offhand comment trying to
have some fun on the internet
there was some random kid who kept
sending me fire memes
and i kept posting them and i would tag
them each time
and the memes were things like me
carrying peter schiff around like a baby
and many other hilarious memes
but then the kid kept sending me more
and more memes
and i finally said to myself this kid
has too much time on his hands
who is he so i messaged the person back
and i said hey
what do you do all day you got a lot of
time for memes what do you do and
that person was colton we eventually got
on a call
and somehow i think colton was getting
on a call to
uh just talk or hang out or meet i don't
really know what
but i got on the call and i pitched him
on starting a company
that i had an idea for but i didn't have
time to do and so
that's what we did and somehow colton
now has quit his job
he still has fire memes and we work
together on the entire employment
business
to help uh what 10 000 people get a job
in crypto this year is our goal
right yep absolutely all right what's
your side of the meme story before we
get started
okay so it was new year's day oh new
year's day
watching football and uh i see you tweet
that out
and i actually truthfully hadn't
followed you for too long
um you just kind of kept showing up in
my timeline i'm like dang this guy has a
podcast like he puts a lot of content
out
obviously respect that what i also
really respected too is that like
you weren't afraid to voice your opinion
on controversial subjects
saying stuff like social socialism is
bad and things like that
is that controversial um and maybe in in
my circles yes
um but uh so i'm like i don't know if i
should send him a meme it's kind of
weird i don't usually do that kind of
thing
um but then i thought of the the peter
schiff idea you holding him like a baby
i thought that was too funny not to send
um so sent you the meme put my phone
down continued watching football
i looked back and you responded so we
kind of went back and forth from there
and honestly uh i didn't have too much
time on my hands i was working
you know a regular job 40 hours a week
and then i was giving baseball lessons
and coaching so like in total probably
like 50 hours a week
and then the memes take up just a small
portion of that
all right the fact that we're
okay did you
did my name catch your attention because
it's so close to
nakamoto no but go tell them what your
last name is
sakamoto and actually found out recently
that so i'm japanese on my
great-grandma's side
she was in nakamoto before she was a
sakamoto
are you claiming that your grandmother
may be satoshi nakamoto
it's possible that my great-grandma
could be satoshi
or at least related to dorian yeah
probably
related to dorian for those that don't
know dorian is the person who uh
if you ever see an asian man portrayed
as uh
uh um and i'm gonna say natoshi uh
as uh satoshi nakamoto uh
that is who it is all right we start
this employment business but it didn't
start as a whole business basically the
original idea was let's create a job
board because i had
tons and tons of people who are dming me
every single day saying i want to work
in the industry how do i work in the
industry where are the open roles can
you please help me
i also knew most of the executives at
the company so
walk through what we did and where we
are right now from a
job board perspective first sure so when
we hopped on that first call
like i didn't know what to expect you
hadn't brought up the job board or
anything
and then you started pitching me so i'm
going wait is this guy pitching me is
this like reverse shark tank like what's
going on here
and so that was going through my head as
this was going on you kind of explained
the problem
um you're like hey i want to create this
job board can you do it and i was like
freaking absolutely i'll do it um i'll
get to work immediately i don't think
you were sold on me yet but i was like
dude yeah absolutely i'll do this
so i started getting to work on it and
the idea was just to
consolidate you know all the jobs across
all the top companies in one space
um obviously you have your linkedins
you're in deeds but
there's not really a ton of crypto jobs
on there so the basic idea is just to
get all the jobs in one space and make
the job search as easy as possible for
job seekers
all right and we've got what companies
like coinbase
gemini block fi who else yeah coinbase
gemini blockfly anchorage in i mean all
the big players in the space and then
tons of startups too and there's
probably
60 to 70 companies who list their roles
every month
right now i think it's a little bit
lighter i think there's like 53 active
ones but a lot of them
kind of this revolving door of coming in
and out every month as their hiring
needs
um kind of continue all right and
in the first let's say 90 days i think
that's the data that uh i know off top
of my head
what was it like something like 30 000
people
uh or there's 30 000 applications that
went to open roles in the first 90 days
correct yeah now i think we're upwards
of 40k
all right and block five is probably
uh the craziest one where blockfi has
hired
what 30 people 28 people something like
that off the job board in like four
months
yeah something like that i think upwards
of 25 last i checked in with them and
it's it's crazy to see the success so
far and um
what i think the most rewarding part
about it is just hearing the success
stories of people that
you know we're working in the
traditional world and then transition or
maybe they're right out of college and
they got their dream job right out of
college and so um
that's been really awesome to see and
then a number of startups have hired
people and
um when we were down in miami at the
bitcoin conference we were approached by
tons of people who said they've gotten
hired through the job board and through
the course which has been awesome to see
it's uh it is pretty crazy when you
think about uh putting together a piece
of technology
you know doing some work to kind of
bring together a two-sided marketplace
and then people are like oh i got a job
now like literally i get paid because of
what you built
uh is pretty uh pretty fascinating yeah
it's awesome to see
um and just yeah providing that
opportunity i mean the job seekers are
doing all the work
so i don't want to take credit for what
they're doing but um if i can make the
job search easier for someone
i'm absolutely going to do it okay
so other than fire memes what do you do
on a day-to-day basis for the job
board well i guess the means take up
most of the time right
um but uh the job board a lot of it is
just kind of like maintenance outreach
you know customer support type stuff and
ultimately a lot of it comes down to
just
like thinking of how we can make it even
easier for companies
and for job seekers too um so a lot of
work goes into that and then yeah just
kind of mapping out
you know what's what's next so
one of the things that's fascinating and
i think why you and i
uh kind of hit it off and started
working together
was uh when we first started talking
about you doing this
i was like hey man uh you know i'll pay
you some cash and then a little bit of
upside
and let's go do it and your first
response to me was
well can i just do no cash and all
upside and i was like bingo
found the right person yes he
yes absolutely somebody willing to bet
on themselves amazing
the next thing that you said to me later
on a couple of weeks later was
hey if we hit x dollars in monthly
revenue i'll quit my job
and i remember being like 50 50 where
this guy's gonna quit his job
i don't know seems to like his job i
think at one point i asked you if you
liked your job and
you didn't say you liked the job you
said you like the people you worked with
all this stuff
so i said okay we'll see and then true
to your word when we hit that number
you quit your job and now you work on
this full time so what was going through
your head when you went to
uh potentially quit your job for uh
somebody you met on the internet uh
in terms of uh sending memes sure yeah i
was definitely weird
um actually the number that we hit was
just kind of this arbitrary number that
um i decided on and the reason being is
like
we didn't know each other so i wanted to
like see how much i could trust you
basically
um just like sort of means test you by
like
kind of writing it out as long as
possible until we hit that number and
like the plan was
to quit the job the whole time i didn't
tell you that
um i was gonna quit i mean i did like my
job i really liked the people i worked
with so it was tough and i i just
graduated college it was like my first
job i'd only been there six months
so it's definitely really weird to turn
around and be like ah pulling the plug
here
but as soon as we hit that number and
treating my word
call up my boss that same day the first
time i called him he went straight to
voicemail i'm like
oh my gosh now i gotta sit here and
think about it even more
uh he calls me back i'm going hey man uh
i'm quitting
that's what you said you just that was
the conversation was like hey i'm
quitting
or was there a little bit more uh a
little bit more
there's a little bit more massaging like
hey i started this thing um
you know i'm quitting blah blah blah and
definitely caught him by surprise he was
super cool about it you know we get
along we still chat
but um definitely caught him by surprise
and then i i don't know if you remember
but i texted you
yo just quit my job and then you caught
me immediately
i thought you were i didn't think you
were gonna do it i thought you were
gonna be too scared
no it was the plan all along all right
well you tricked me so congratulations
this next thing we figured out was uh
through the job board all of these uh
hr uh people uh recruiters at some of
the large
companies they started to say to us man
this is amazing we're getting
so many applications the problem is
they're great at what they do
but they don't know anything about
bitcoin or crypto so they don't know
anything about
uh what bitcoin is how it works we don't
know anything about
defy or any of this other stuff but
they're great at customer service
or they're great at accounting or
they're great at marketing and so this
is where the
training program or the crypto course
comes in so describe a little bit about
what that program
is and how that works sure so i actually
got brought into the course
about the same time we launched the job
board i remember you dm me
hey you know i'm starting this course do
you want to help out and i had no clue
what the course was
talked with some people at maven kind of
got up to speed so we ran
the beta cohort you obviously teach it
live twice a week
and that was pretty much the the bones
of it what we
found you know through the beta cohort
is that
so many people want to transition um
they don't really
know a whole lot about crypto but they
realize this is this emerging industry
that's going to create
you know hundreds thousands of jobs and
they don't know how to transition maybe
they don't get in front of the right
people or they don't have the knowledge
also paired with that is that the
companies they're finding really quality
people like you mentioned
but they just don't have the basic
crypto understanding
a lot of people actually don't really
believe that when we tell them that but
we're actually teaching
a class for coinbase for their employees
who
are really good employees but just maybe
don't have the level of understanding
so what the course aims to do is
consolidate all the information you do a
really good job of explaining the crypto
basics
we host discussion groups throughout the
week basically every day of the week
there's an event
that you can attend if you want and then
the idea is to
obviously educate them but then get them
in front of as many recruiters as
possible
so what we do at the end is we host a
job fair where these companies come in
they pitch their companies to the job
seekers
they tell them exactly what they're
looking for give them resume tips give
them interview tips
share their open roles share their
company mission so that people aren't
just hearing it from us
but they're actually getting it directly
from the source as to what these
companies
are looking for in addition to that too
we also bring back our alumni who have
been hired
they host discussion groups where they
share you know helpful tips
and it's really just this awesome
ecosystem where you know it's really
collaborative people are willing to
to share helpful tips and to you know um
get them in front of the right people
and things like that
so with the course it's three weeks
every tuesday and thursday when it's
running
we do an hour to an hour and a half so
call it two to three hours
per week for three weeks and then on the
days where there isn't a live class with
me teaching
we have breakout sessions discussion
groups happy hours
etc and the general sense is that
somebody can come in with no knowledge
whatsoever
and they can leave prepared with the
crypto knowledge needed to get hired at
a company in the space
not everyone is trying to get hired
obviously not everyone wants a job
uh but that increasingly is why people
are
signing up explain a little bit about
uh one of the problems obviously is that
right now the way that we run the
cohorts uh which we do every month is
that uh
individuals pay for it so you want to
get a job you pay for the course
you get kind of the certification of the
training and then you go ahead
and we help you get in front of
recruiters um and there's been people
who have been hired at coinbase gemiini
blockfi
kraken etc that have gone through the
course
it'd be awesome if the companies paid
for it
because then it removes the barrier
or the friction for the individuals to
pay for it and so we're running this
pilot
with coinbase talk a little bit about
what we're doing there and kind of how
that program works
we're trying to get these companies to
come in and a lot of expressed interest
in
providing scholarships so that's that's
kind of in the works and then in terms
of
coinbase um what we do is they have a
continuing education program
and they have a lot of people who might
not know a lot about
crypto or just want to continue to learn
we teach a similar class it's not really
cohort based because it doesn't offer
the same benefits that a cohort based
course would
but it's weekly for an hour hour and a
half and we just go over pretty much the
basics do q a and that kind of thing
so the idea with coinbase is that
they've already hired these people
and rather than do some sort of internal
uh crypto onboarding we're basically
testing is it better for
us to just run this uh every month
for new hires at coinbase and so they
don't have to worry about at the
recruiting department
are we hiring people who have both the
skill set necessary to do the job plus
the crypto knowledge
they can just focus on let's hire the
best people who do the job and then
we'll teach them
uh the crypto kind of basics yeah and i
think the goal with the
um the training course is to eliminate
the need for companies to do that
obviously
you know if companies do have people you
know you want to educate them but
the the idea is to bring the job speaker
up to speed
um before what's up guys bang bang
i hope you're enjoying this conversation
but before we go any further i want to
quickly tell you about today's sponsor
blockfy blockfy's got four different
financial products for crypto investors
you can deposit crypto and earn up to
8.6 apy
in an interest bearing account you can
deposit crypto and take out a us dollar
loan against your crypto collateral
you can use their cryptocurrency
exchange and have no trading fees
or you can get a new bitcoin rewards
credit card it's a normal credit card
that when you swipe
you get bitcoin back rather than cash
back or airline miles
i'm an investor in the business and a
very happy user i think you will be too
when you go to blockfy.com pomp
again blockfy.com go check it out and
let me know what you think
all right let's get back into this
conversation i hope you enjoy it
what's your favorite part so far of
uh the job boarding course and what has
been the worst part
oh tough question no lying you better be
honest
okay i will um honestly
it i have so much fun and i look forward
to it so much this weekend i went um
camping took some time off
um and everyone was talking about how
they're dreading going back to their
jobs and i'm sitting there thinking like
i can't wait for monday like we get to
do this over again let's go
let's bring it and it's been really
awesome to work with you you know your
brothers freaking goofballs
jordy matt caroline felina everyone so
everyone's just really cool to work with
too
i really like having the autonomy and
you've done a really good job of
kind of you know passing the reins to me
and letting me figure it out on my own
which i really appreciate
um so i like kind of having the autonomy
to
take it in whichever direction i see fit
but in terms of stuff i don't like
i don't know i mean it's definitely a
lot of work you know there's weeks where
i have to put in 80 plus hours and
that's just the way it is but
i don't see that as a negative thing um
and then also another good benefit of it
too is just seeing the fruits of the
labor like seeing people get hired and
like feeling like i'm making an impact
not only with people but in the industry
as well
i thought you were going say uh one of
the downsides was the uh notification
system that we have
notification system yeah so for those
that don't know
uh increasingly uh i've given up on all
communication platforms
you email me there's a 50 50 whether i
see it you text me
50 50 whether i see it you dm me on a
platform there's a zero percent chance
i'm seeing it
just literally i can't keep up anymore
and so
most people let's say they text me they
think that i'm like
uh discriminating against them they're
like oh he doesn't like me anymore he's
not responding to my text i'm like no
literally like
other than my wife pretty much
everybody's in the same bucket
so explain the notification system that
we have
backed into here that ensures that i get
things done that you need me to do
yeah so i said that you gave me full
autonomy and that's true but there are
certain things that
um that you might need to get done that
are blocking other things from happening
um you know basic example is just like
tweeting out the job board hey we're low
on job views we need to get this thing
out there
to the public we need to drive
distribution so i'll
text you and then like we'll hear back
um
maybe i'll text you again we'll hear
back and you said hey just keep bugging
me like
my phone's a mess whatever so what i did
to try to try and make it funny and less
annoying is like
i turned it into basically an automated
text like one of those ones you'd get
from a solicitor like reply stop to
cancel the message
[Laughter]
so i literally get text from him that
says
please tweet out job board link reply
and then in all caps
stop to stop receiving notifications and
it'll text it to me sometimes like i'll
be in a meeting and i'll get out and i
have like three text messages
and they'll all say the same thing and
he'll just keep sending it to me until i
respond with like
lol or stop or some [ __ ] so that he
knows that i actually tweeted out the
link
when it worked five once we get to five
which hasn't happened yet
thank god uh i'm sending a reminder to
polina and caroline
and i'll be on them every hour
that's the real secret is if anyone no i
can't say that because then everyone
will go talk to plane and she'll get mad
uh but yeah if uh if there's an
emergency
polina is a good outlet to uh to make
sure that uh that i'm paying attention
to something
all right 10 000 jobs
in the industry you think we're gonna do
this
how realistic is that ten thousand jobs
uh that we helped fill
in 2021 so i've actually put a lot of
thought into it
and when you first said 10 000 i'm like
why is this guy saying 10 000 that's
such an absurd goal
like probably not possible but let me
kind of walk you through
what i think and then i want to get your
perspective as well
i've heard you talk about slugging
percentage not batting average and me
coming from a baseball background that
makes a lot of sense
basically like you want to swing for the
fences that's
you're going to be up there anyways you
might as well make a count you might as
well shoot the three-pointer you might
as well go for the touchdown
so i think the 10 000 goal while it is
such a big number
i think that you know if we said oh
we're only going to help
50 people then you start selling
yourself short you start going up there
trying to slap a single the other way
and that's just plain old boring
we want to hit freaking bombs um so i
think the 10 000 goal is
a little bit on the higher end for sure
but i think you start selling yourself
short when you
settle for something less than that but
i think ultimately
this ecosystem is only in the beginning
i think it's going to be one of those
things where
you know it's one of those mass job
creation events like the internet
we don't know what's going to happen
when the the global economy is is
brought together
through through bitcoin um so i think
there's going to be a downstream effect
of that and just going to be this mass
job creation
event where maybe jobs we don't even
think of maybe it's going to enable the
creator economy
before i mean when the internet was
created we didn't think there was going
to be like things like uber and lyft and
um things like that so i just think that
we're only in the beginning and i think
that you know we're well on our way to
helping 10 000 people whether it's this
year next or the year after that it's
gonna happen
all right my thought process is ten
thousand isn't even a high number
right think of it maybe for it's not but
maybe for one year
well hold on think of it this way we've
had 40 000 applications go in
right on the uh job board so far
and in five months right basically we
stopped we started at the end of january
beginning of february like sometime
around there
so end of june be five months give or
take
if that continues there will be over
a hundred thousand applications that go
in
on uh the job board if ten percent get
higher there's ten thousand people right
there
now it's probably not ten thousand right
so maybe it's
five percent or seven percent or you
know whatever the number ends up being
but it's not
zero percent uh and it's definitely not
you know fifty percent so somewhere in
between we don't know yet but we gotta
figure that out but it's gonna be a
hundred thousand applications
that go into all the major companies the
second thing
is that there's an ever expanding number
of job opportunities
available so as more companies get
created as companies get larger
right there's more and more
opportunities which means that uh
there's
uh more potential roles to fill
then you add in the course uh in this
training program
and right now we're doing you know let's
call it a hundred people
or so per month and so by the end of the
year that'd be
over a thousand but likely we'll
continue to scale that up and maybe we
start doing you know 200 250 once we
kind of figure out the logistics of it
and so very quickly you could see like
in a given year a hundred plus thousand
applications go in
on the job board and maybe we do let's
call it 5
000 people uh or you know 3 000 people
through the training course i don't
think that's too crazy to think that we
could get 10 000 people hired in a
single year
very true that's a good point i didn't
think of it like that right
then you start adding in other things
we're going to create other stuff i
don't know what else yet but like we'll
create other things
that'll help as well and if we just keep
trying to solve the problem
of how do we help individuals get
themselves
in front of recruiters at these
companies uh kind of in
the most prepared best light and then we
do things to help recruiters
uh and people at the hr departments of
these companies
understand that the folks that we're
bringing to them whether it's
in a more automated fashion like the job
board something like the training
program or whatever else we create
that they're high quality that they're
uh well trained that they have the base
knowledge needed to be successful within
the organization
it feels like over time uh you end up
actually reducing the friction rather
than increasing it
and so you should see a higher and
higher conversion percentage
uh over time if we do our jobs right
yeah that's a good point i think you
bring up something that i didn't really
consider there's like an exponential
aspect to this
a because we just started both the
training course and the job board
but i mean companies are ramping up
hiring like crazy especially through the
bull market and hopefully that's going
to continue who knows
but they need to bring on tons of people
too so as as
this you know as the industry continues
as bitcoin continues
you know to where we think it's going to
go it's only going to create more
opportunities
all right before we get into rapid fire
questions and then you're going to get
to ask me one question at the end which
scares the hell out of me
uh where can people go to the job board
and where can they find out more about
the
course yeah so the job board
pomcryptojobs.com
you'll tweet it out quite a bit all
tweeted out quite a bit i'll plug my own
twitter at cj sakamoto15
had to and then the course is just
palmscriptofcourse.com
all right pompcryptojobs.com and
dot pomcryptocourse.com comscript of
course dot com pomps with an s
with an s all right go check those out
we run the
uh course and training program every
month
and there are hundreds of job openings
on the job board make sure you go check
that out all right here we go rapid fire
ready
yep what's the most important book
you've ever read
um i'm gonna go with the bible um
you know it's kind of a cliche answer
but just you know pretty good
um moral guidance and you can you know
take it for what it's worth interpret it
however you want but
um like i said it's number one that's a
great answer
uh second question is your sleep
schedule i'm sleeping on eight sleep
everybody knows it what uh what's your
sleep schedule
so when we first launched terrible um i
don't know if you remember
the day we launched the job board i
think he launched it at
eight am eastern time five five a.m my
time i was up and you're like dude what
are you doing up i was like i couldn't
sleep man
and through that whole process of
creating the job board up until only a
few months ago it was probably
pretty bad um i would be a great case
study for your friends at eight sleep
because i'm truly
an idiot if i don't get um adequate
sleep like spelling grammar
out the window i'm just like not all
there i'm a complete zombie
so um especially you know during my
collegiate baseball career i was someone
who had to sleep
eight nine hours a night i recently got
this whoop so i've been tracking turning
into a competition
um seeing how much room i can get last
night i got two hours 39 minutes around
um having crazy dreams
that's all right it's not a great number
but it's not a horrible number
what's your rental bike oh i'm like five
hours for sure no problem no not a rab
i don't know what it is i don't know all
right uh aliens believer or non-believer
i don't know um i think that the whole
ufo thing is i don't think they're
aliens i think
um obviously they're just unidentified
that doesn't mean they're
extraterrestrial
i think that i think that there's
probably life out there i don't know how
advanced
i mean if you were to like break it down
from like statistics standpoint
it would only make sense because of how
big things are but also you have to
factor in
like all the conditions to have
intelligent life too i mean distance
from the sun
water whatever so um
one big i don't know i agree with you
that unidentified
objects uh flying objects ufos does not
mean that they're aliens i definitely
agree
about that one guy like a couple months
ago saying there's like tunnels under
mars or some
crap like that boring company obviously
that's what elon's doing he's practicing
true he's a martian i'm kind of with
elon like
you know show me something that doesn't
look like a 7-eleven atm
picture and then and then maybe i'll
believe
all right what question do you have for
me i know you've been planning this so
i'm scared but what question do you have
for me
i've wanted to ask you this for a long
time
who do you think would win in a fight a
silverback gorilla
or a grizzly bear silverback gorilla not
even close
i don't know are you sure have you seen
a bear claw something before
have you seen a gorilla lose at anything
have you seen a pair lose at anything
yes i saw a woman smack a bear where
that was sitting on that
backyard that bear was literally slapped
and ran away so i was kind of yeah i was
kind of leaning towards
team bear until i saw that video and i
think
she was like 19 or something um
so i don't know i don't think like the
bear got beat up by a 19 year old girl
yeah i don't think a girl would go down
like that the only way you're taking out
a
uh gorilla is if it's a harambe like an
inside job that's the only way that
you're
uh taking out gorillas yeah all right
i don't know i've yet to see it happen
so i
i think i'm gonna go with gorilla too
but you gotta compare like so many
things you gotta compare the size the
reach
um you know biting how strong their bite
is
claws no claws i think we got to do a
combine
you think a bear is beating a gorilla
i don't know but i think it's a better
fight than you
than you're letting on to be how much
time have you spent thinking about this
a lot of time and it's like this ongoing
debate with with my friends too
um and it goes back and forth quite a
bit as new information is presented
we're obviously in intellectuals so as
you know information comes up we
definitely have to take that into
consideration
what do you guys do out there in
portland
you guys don't really have that much
else to do other than uh
talk about who wins bears or gorillas do
you guys own bears and gorillas can you
like
see it can you like put it together no
only at the zoo
um it's like a ripley's believe it or
not watch this bear
fight this gorilla you'd sell tons and
tons
of uh of folks to uh come and buy
tickets
yeah portland's crazy i wouldn't be
surprised if you saw a barren
gorilla go at it on the streets
it wouldn't be the craziest thing that
portland's had to offer it would not be
it would not be uh all right pomp
krypto
and pompscryptocourse.com
if people are looking for jobs that's
where they should go yep
and if they want to harass you with
questions about how to get hired in the
industry
at cj sakamoto
15 yep just like nakamoto but with an
s why number 15 uh it was my baseball
number
nothing too creative behind that why
number 15 for baseball
um i don't know i just like they kept
giving me number 15.
uh until i got to gardner-webb when i
was four and then i was like too far
down to change my twitter handle
yeah but five minus one equals four so
like it works
hey now you put it like that yeah you're
right
yeah i mean i'm not a genius i'm just a
mathematician
on the internet all right at cj sakamoto
15
pomp pompcryptojobs.com or
pompscriptofcourse.com
let's go get 10 000 people hired this
year
so that colton who doesn't yet realize
that if we do it in this
calendar year means we did it in 11
months not 12 because we started at the
end of january
yep we could prove him wrong and then
he'll have to tell me that i was right
which is all i live for
all right man thanks for thanks for
doing this we'll do it again soon maybe
we'll bring on some people who've been
hired
and they can tell their stories cool
thanks for having me